- [Mark] Alright, Rita.
- Hi.
- [Mark] How are you?
- Fine, 'cause I came over here.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- [Rita] Yeah, I got a family.
'Cause my old man
is a truck driver,
he looks just like you
and he lives in Big Bear
but he visits me every year.
- [Mark] So how are you doing
now, you're living where?
- I'm living on the corner.
- [Mark] You're at SRO hotel.
- I don't know the street.
Yes, I got a house now. By my own self.
And they're going to help
me with a TV and stuff.
But I got a bed. I got everything.
- [Mark] So you have your own room?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Much nicer than
living on the street.
- Yeah. And they give me
a full box once a week.
- [Mark] So you're getting
treated a little better.
- Yeah, a lot better.
Somebody must have reported.
But yes, they're treating me real good.
And when I come here, it just be all day.
(Rita giggles)
- [Mark] That's great.
And are you still doing things
for money that you used to?
- No. I don't prostitute no more.
- [Mark] You don't?
- Y'all helped me a whole lot.
- [Mark] Who helped you a lot?
- You, Mark.
(Mark and Rita laugh)
Mark helped me.
- Yeah, I guess I did.
- And I don't even go panhandle for food
at the Union Station.
- You don't?
- Nope.
I don't.
I got food right now.
- So you're much happier now?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's great. You seem happier.
- I just gotta be cleaner, but I'm happy.
- [Mark] Your hair looks great.
- I got food now.
They gave us a food box
yesterday with real TV dinners.
- [Mark] That's nice.
- Yeah. I just want some
underclothes and some hygiene.
- [Mark] So where do you think
your life will go from here?
You've got a nice place to stay--
- I want to try to be on
"Dancing with the Stars".
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] You should. You
should try to do that.
- I am, 'cause I was singing
in front of that building.
A lot of people just
happy and feeling good,
telling me to sing different songs.
- [Mark] Good to have
dreams. That's great.
- Yeah. They wanted me to sing songs for--
(mumbles)
- [Mark] You're a good dancer?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You are?
- I could dance.
I make up my own dance.
Yeah.
I can.
But yeah, I'm happy.
- [Mark] That's great.
I'm not a prostitute no more.
And I'm not a beggar.
I used to go to Union Station
and I used to go downtown
by grocery stores, 7-11.
But I don't do that.
I ain't did it in two months now
since I been here.
- [Mark] Awesome.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's nice to hear.
- [Mark] You deserve to have
a nice break in your life.
You've had such a rough--
- Yeah.
And then there's a lady at
St. Monica look like my mother
and she said that I come
and stay with her anytime.
And she gave me some clothes.
She my size, but she's
Caucasian with yellow hair.
And she gave me some clothes that day.
She fed me.
We went to the malls and stuff.
- [Mark] Oh, that's nice.
- Yeah. She took a picture and
then she gave me some money.
- [Mark] So you have some people
being nice to you.
- So I gotta--yeah.
- [Mark] There's people being
nice to you now.
- A play mother.
Yes. At St. Monica I really got family.
Over there
by the Broadway.
- [Mark] It's 'cause you're
a movie star now, right?
- Yeah. I am.
Everybody in my building
say I'm a movie star.
(Mark laughs)
Yeah. I am.
That's why I came to California
to be on TV to be like--
- [Mark] OK, well maybe I helped
you with that little dream.
- Yeah. 'Cause I could dance.
- [Mark] Yeah, the dancing part
I'm not sure if I can help you with.
- And I could make-- You don't?
I could dance good. And I could sing.
I had a lot of people
last night feeling good.
- [Mark] Are you still using
crack sometimes?
- Crack? Yeah.
- [Mark] You do?
That's hard to get rid of, right?
- 'Cause God say I gotta tell the truth.
Yeah.
- [Mark] That's a hard drug to stop using.
- Yeah.
But I don't go to the program.
It just, when it run out, it run out.
But when I need things, I get them first.
And if I'm too tired and
stuff, I don't go hustle.
Nothing. It's just done.
I don't cause problems to get it.
No, that's it.
Sometimes it's nasty to me now, lately.
For some reason I come here.
It's nasty.
I feel like, you know, famous.
I feel better than I used to be.
I'll be walking and they be
wanting to sell me stuff.
I be like, uh uh, I've got
something positive to do for God.
- [Mark] What makes you feel
good? Having nice clothes?
- [Rita] Looking nice, being clean.
- [Mark] Yeah, you said to me clothes.
- [Rita] And clean, like the
other lady been. Looking nice.
That's all it is, man. Looking nice.
Yep. And I'm gaining weight at first.
- [Mark] Oh, you're you're gaining weight.
- [Rita] Yeah. I eat more
since you've been helping me.
I eat more. I used to
go two and three days
without eating, just smoking crack.
But I eat a lot now.
- [Mark] That's good.
- [Rita] Yeah. And I
don't think about crack.
I eat.
Just be like normal people.
- [Mark] So, are you using less crack?
- [Rita] Yeah.
- Oh, you are!
- [Rita] I smoke like three times a week.
I used to smoke every day.
- [Mark] Hm.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's great.
- [Rita] I smoked last night,
but I don't got a taste for it.
That's how it ain't
something I have to do.
- [Mark] That's not.
- If I'm around people.
- [Mark] It's just hard to
be in this neighborhood.
- [Rita] Yeah.
- [Mark] 'Cause everyone's doing it.
- [Rita] Come on, I stopped doing it.
Somebody come to my door
and knock and give me stuff.
- [Mark] Of course they do.
- [Rita] Yep. Free.
And then when they see me next time
they just tell me to give more money.
- [Mark] Hmm.
- [Rita] Yeah.
I ain't took a shower or nothing.
'cause I was smoking,
but I'm going to get some
clothes or something.
And look pretty. Take a shower.
I'm not going to go to sleep, though,
'cause I've been smoking.
- [Mark] But you're sleeping good,
and you're eating good now?
- [Rita] Yeah. For
real. Especially eating.
I used to be real skinny,
but even they noticed
they say I'm gaining a lot of weight.
- [Mark] And you're using less
crack, which I think helps
gain weight, right?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
I used to be 114.
Now I'm 126.
Since I met you. Yeah.
'Cause I went to the
doctor, 'cause I got COPD.
And when I did that Corona
thing, they said, it's an area.
They didn't know if I had it or not.
So I had to go to the real hospital
and they said I didn't have it.
- [Mark] No, you seem great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Excellent, Rita.
So nice seeing you again.
- Yeah. And without asking for money.
Cause you made me feel bad now.
I want to be like Jeff.
- [Mark] Everybody asks me for money.
- Yeah. But without money.
Just to be--
Come dressed up like Titi now, man.
You helped me get--
I know my sister now and showed my sister
I'm a star now on real TV.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] You are.
Ha! And that means a star
because of this YouTube, right?
- [Mark] You are a star!
- [Rita] Yeah. Thank you.
- [Mark] We're going to make you famous.
- [Rita] Yeah. Yeah.
'Cause my sister said that
she's happy for me now.
- [Mark] Just gotta get you a manager now.
- She got to see for yourself.
Yeah. It ain't just money.
I just want my sister
to see I'm--you know--
be clean and pretty.
Yeah.
- Cool!
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You wanna dance for me?
- Yeah. You don't got no music.
- [Mark] I don't have any
music, I'm sorry. Next time.
- [Rita] But my sister works
for Sacramento Elementary,
and she's a minister.
And she got a drill team
going for the girls,
and she had them doing
some stuff, too, back home.
TV and the phone and stuff.
- [Mark] Oh, fun.
- [Rita] Yeah. She's gonna
get me in a little while.
I just started visiting.
- [Mark] There you go.
- [Rita] Okay.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
- [Rita] Thank you, Jesus.
(faintly speaking)